the West family is expanding to a family
of six new year new baby
Kim and Kanye are expecting baby number
four via surrogate a source tells ET the
couple has always wanted a big family
and their first time with service e went
so well they decided to do it again
they've also talked that after this
child they are most likely done having
kids
now Kim reportedly had one embryo left
and it's a boy according to Us Weekly
he's reportedly due to arrive in May
2019 ok so last month et caught up with
Kim at her k'kaw Beauty pop-up shop
where she opened up about adding a new
addition to the family in 2019 I know
you've talked about it could we get
another little one number 4
you never know but I think after that I
mean that's that's a lot three is alive
three you realizing it's a lot lately
yeah it's you know cuz everyone needs
your attention today I was a little bit
late cuz my son is sick and you know he
didn't want me to leave and it's so hard
so I do want to make sure that I have
enough time for everybody because having
kids it's just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot that's like
the best way I know how to describe it
Kim yeh brought in the new year with
their little ones in tow at the family's
New Year's Eve party eleven month old
Chicago three year old Saint and five
year old
North but of course fans couldn't help
but notice North's bold makeup guys this
one is rough so many were outraged that
she was rocking red lipstick a color
that isn't considered age-appropriate
for a five-year-old is Kim prepping
north to take over the family business I
don't know guys but it seems really
risky she's five years old let's give
her a break from makeup okay moving on
Kim seems to be easygoing with her kids
we asked if nori would take over mom's
beauty business one day and here's what
she said is she a beauty mogul in the
making will she take over for you one
day she definitely loves makeup if she
loves it enough she can definitely take
it over whatever she wants to do when
she is old enough she can do now North
isn't the only westering up a little
social media controversy because Kanye
wants a public apology from Drake for
fall
Kim Kardashian on Instagram okay so
tensions were at an all-time high back
in September and yay seemed to add fuel
to the fire he wrote in a now series of
deleted tweets whose bright idea wasn't
to tell Drake to follow my wife on
Instagram this person is not Drake's
friend he dodged me for months when I
extended olive branches to talk and then
call to threaten me okay so we checked
and Drake does not follow Kim on
Instagram thank God let's in this please
as Kanye put it tweeting is legal and
also therapeutic for him so keep on
tweeting Kanye go through a lot and he's
just the most genuine person and you
know he might say things that might get
misinterpreted and people don't see the
context behind it but I always know his
heart
so despite Kanye's rants he seems to be
a pretty good dad and another boy will
balance things out a bit and give Saint
a partner in crime of course we will
keep you updated on the West and their
new additions be sure to subscribe to
all things et until next time I'm at
Kourtney underscore tezo bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]